(dramatic music)
- [Protestors] Deport gays, deport gays,
God is great, deport gays!
- [Michael] I'd walk down the
hall and get called “faggot”
by some folks.
- [Protestor] Get rid of 'em.
(cheering)
- A friend of mine says,
"You know, Michael,
"you weren't the first
homosexual at P&G
"but you sure did put a public face
"to it in the '80s."
(protestors chanting)
(dramatic music)
- [Woman] We will have civil rights
for gay people.
- Oh boy, Cincinnati in the '80s.
(sighs)
It was kind of a risky thing,
being known as gay then.
- [News Announcer] AIDS has struck 1,640--
- You had a life span of six months,
maybe 18 months if you were lucky.
There weren't effective remedies then.
- Procter and Gamble
really found this niche
with Peridex prescription mouthwash
being used by people with AIDS.
- There was this disconnect.
P&G wanted to do the science,
they wanted to do the marketing,
but they didn't quite get,
because they weren't gay,
that these are people's lives.
- Things were not good
for the LGBT community.
In P&G, the words
“sexual orientation” were
not in the EEO policy statement.
- You know, where are the gays?
Where are the lesbians?
- [Man] The words needed to be there.
- They were not ready to embrace that.
They were not wanting to embrace it.
- [Man] In no way was
Michael going to back away.
- I just kept at it.
- He was willing to put it on the line.
- He was willing to be an outlier.
- It's either gonna take you
or you're gonna take it.
And I had made up my mind.
- Policies do matter.
Taking a stand matters.
Words matter.
- It's important to
understand the struggle
because the truth is, we're
always in the struggle.